It's no secret that in order
for your app to be successful,
the user has to run it, and for
it continue to provide value,
sometimes it needs
to keep running.
This is tough to do when
the phone is asleep.
I mean, what are you going
to do, wake up the phone
and do the work even though
it's already sleeping?
Well yes, of course, but be
careful here because there's
a large battery problem
waiting to happen.
My name is Colt McAnlis, and
disturbing your phone's beauty
sleep is one of the biggest
causes of unneeded battery
drain on Android, but
with a few simple changes
to how you're working, you
can achieve the same results
with less battery problems.
To illustrate this point, let's
talk about my good friend Rado.
He's an avid social
user and a game player,
which means his running
applications are constantly
checking scoreboards, uploading
photos, and pulling down
the latest hashtag
crazes, but they
do this even when Rado has
put his phone to sleep, which
means by lunch, his phone
is already out of battery.
Rado has to constantly
recharge his phone
because it suffers
from sleep deprivation.
That is, because these
applications are constantly
waking up the phone, they're
eating up battery life
instead of letting his phone
sleep, and sleep is important.
Remember that
Android will turn off
various parts of your
hardware in order
to prolong battery life.
First, the screen will dim,
followed by it eventually
turning off, and
finally, the CPU
will go to sleep, all in an
attempt to save precious,
precious battery.
But even in this inactive state,
most apps will try to do work,
and they will have to wake
up the phone to do so.
Now, the easiest way for an
app to wake up your phone
to do work is with the
PowerManager.Wakelock API,
which is used to
keep the CPU running
and prevent the screen from
dimming or turning off.
This allows your phone
to do things like wake
up at some future
point, do some work,
and then let the phone
go back to sleep.
But see, it's that last
part that's the tricky one.
See, acquiring Wakelock
is actually really easy,
but knowing how to release
it is more problematic.
There's lots of ways that
this can go horribly wrong.
What if your application
takes 60 minutes instead
of the expected 10
seconds it takes
to analyze some image before
uploading it to the server?
Or what if the server
crashes and you never
get a response from
your social media ping,
and you end up waiting
forever for a result?
The end result is the phone
never sleeps and chews
through your battery, which is
exactly why you should be using
the version of wakelock.acquire
that takes a timeout parameter.
This will force the
Wakelock to be released
after a certain amount of time
just in case one of these edge
cases actually happens.
But this won't actually
solve the problem fully.
I mean, what should you set
the timeout value to be,
or how long should you wait
before trying to do it again
in case you actually
fail the first time?
The right solution to this
might be to use inexact timers.
See, normally, you set some
future date for your event
to kick off and
wake up the phone,
but it might be better
to change that timing
in order to conserve battery.
For example, if there's
another application that
needs to wake up five minutes
after yours has requested to,
it's optimal to
wait for that one
to happen so that you can
bundle the work together.
This is at the core of
what inexact timers do.
You can schedule some
work for the future,
but if the system detects
that there's a better time,
it can delay your work
in order to save battery.
And in reality, there's a
whole group of other situations
that might be better to
do battery intensive work,
for example, when the phone is
charging or connected to Wi-Fi
or already woken up
by another process.
If any of your work can be
deferred to a future date
when these conditions
might be ideal,
then you can help improve
battery life significantly.
This is exactly what the
JobScheduler API is for.
See, this API is perfect to
schedule some future work
to wait for various combinations
of these better conditions,
for example, waiting until
the unit is plugged in,
waiting until you're
on Wi-Fi, or batching
a bunch of these tasks
together at once.
Basically, with
one simple API, you
get all that
scheduling for free.
And don't forget with the new
revamped battery usage details
on the phone, users
now have the ability
to see how long your app is
keeping their phone awake for
and even have the
ability to uninstall it
right from the same screen,
which means you should probably
take a few extra
minutes and make sure
that all of your wakelock logic
is in order using the Battery
Historian tool.
This tool rolled out with
the L release of Android
and can help you understand
how often wakes are kicked off,
who initialized them,
and how long they lasted,
all in a nice visual package.
With these new tools and APIs,
you can finally give that sleep
deprived phone some
well deserved rest.
But of course, if you would
like to avoid sleeping,
then check out the rest of the
Android Performance Patterns
resources and don't forget
to join our Google+ community
as well.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember
perf matters.
[MUSIC PLAYING]